you
how are my favorite Millennials are we
gonna start every show like that now I
think we have to okay so with our hands
on our hips like this today is Friday
the 13th which means it's gonna be a
particularly smooth and a spooky day oh
yeah but episode more importantly yeah I
love a good spooky episode um I'm
feeling spooky I had a nightmare last
night actually really yeah Margo this is
actually like so me and actually leave
me MARTA
yeah me and my girl got it's like a
drunken fight or whatever and like she
was like being irrational but like she
was drunk so I wanted to take care of
her and she like kept walking away from
me and I'm like I know I'm mad at you
but I'm not gonna leave you because
you're my sister I'm like it's late at
night and you're drunk so then she
started to jog because she knew I
couldn't jog like I keep up with her I
mean no but she didn't do that in real
life and that's your own like self no
but like that that's what I think of
Margo that's your own subconscious
all right that's mean on here yes so
maybe it's time to start jogging I feel
like you're gonna pull a Carol I'm like
the woman who's noticing but it's gonna
like run the marathon I have to be
honest I finished yesterday's episode
the other episode of really after the
show yesterday and when you said he
started crying at the marathon I was
like damn loser wiener but I I started
tearing up because it really is like
such an accomplishment it was me so
overwhelming like and I just loved the
sight of people standing there with
signs like yeah it just makes me tear up
yeah like I don't wanna run the marathon
I just want to watch someone do it and
then have a sign at the end we did that
once for Olivia it was the half man and
we barely made it in time please that
was treacherous and was raining yeah I
was sweating more than I my house is a
Brooklyn house yeah we went to Brooklyn
Prospect Park and it was so early it was
I can it was so early it was horrible it
was pretty tough I'm so glad she's like
over that thing we're shocked that she
almost ran the regular marathon but she
started with the half like to but I feel
like for us for her to run the regular
marathon would be better once it's in
New York - it goes longer so we could
have woken up late like one yeah and
she's damn slow she'd probably be like
the last one she get picked up by the
truck you know I'm getting I can't
believe she didn't get picked up by the
truck like I would have 100% but Cheech
and no total but she did train she was
training for the real marathon yeah but
then obviously that was unrealistic I'm
glad she started with the half but she
should have went to the pho yeah I can't
believe she ran 13 miles like that's
crazy that's crazy I feel like I get it
I don't know if I'll ever run the
marathon because I just don't want to
ever be I know that I won't said I ran
might be training for the marathon or be
like I was my friends to be like I can't
I'm training for the marathon like I
don't want those words to ever come out
of my mouth but it does it definitely
seems like a high okay I don't know I
don't care to explore those feelings you
know
yeah but as always this is the morning
toast I'm girl with no job Claudia
Australia I'm Jackie O problems yeah we
are sorry we are here to deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast we have some
amazing stories for you so genomic our
first one of course we just need to keep
you updated on the Khloe Kardashian
three days in a row third trimester
Thompson drama three days in a row Khloe
has been our first story and yesterday
we said that Chloe was probably in labor
as we speak which was true because right
after the show it was announced that she
gave birth to a baby girl with Tristan
in the room as well as her sisters Kim
tweeted this morning that it's a
beautiful baby and that she held up
Chloe's leg of course she did will you
hold up my leg of course will you let me
hold up yours oh I don't know there's
that's a difference I feel like my birth
will be very very private like will Zack
be there probably
no doctor like XML talk to her female
doctor um look up in your vision do you
care I don't care I just whoever's best
for the job do you have a male or female
gynecologist no me too yeah that's
that's that's like I guess like what
kind of man I can't handle having a male
kind of house yeah how am I gonna have a
handle having a male but like what kind
of demand my pets to grow up and be a
guy no that's weird you left at the end
like who marries a male gynecologist
like that I know I'm like a fella with a
friend that both of her parents are kind
ecologist like that's key that's cute
yeah yeah like when I was in the eighth
grade um this girl in my was really my
great who I've spoken out the show a lot
Alex Brazell her mom is a gynecologist I
have a question this is a chicken and
egg situation was she a toaster
before you spoke better I heard about it
or she heard you were talking about her
on the show I don't know me man
what one of my hairs was in my mouth oh
my oh it's disgusting
probably the worst thing in the world no
honestly the worst feeling in the world
is like what a hair goes down your butt
crack but if you want to give it you
wanna get technical okay whatever so her
mom had to come and and talk to us about
our vaginas
okay you always say that I read the
comments too much and like this is the
second time ever five minutes and like
you would not listen to both sides
people are saying interesting stuff like
when you're in labor you don't care who
is getting up well that's true that's
true
that's sure it's good just say my story
get it out of me yeah so Alex Brazil's
mom is a gynecologist and she actually
delivered a bunch of babies in our
school she delivered Abe oh my god
that's really cute and she's one of my
best friends gynecologist I feel like
that she's a logano kind of client
confidentiality so I won't you just
exploited it no but I'm not gonna see
what you're inside do you know which
room no who oh really yeah oh my gosh
she wouldn't care yeah okay so the guy
know Alex was Noah's mom I'm forgetting
her name I think I might be Jude a
doctor was a doctor uh yeah
actually she was by her maiden name but
she came to us in the eighth grade and
we had to submit anonymous because like
she thought people would be embarrassed
like raise our hands she was totally
right
so everyone likes um if you had a
question about your vagina like you
would submit like anonymously in the
gyno read them out and she was like well
and there was this one question that was
like so bio becoming friend my friend
Lucy like claiming that she wrote it but
yeah but like the questions were insane
like four eighth graders ready one of
the questions was I'm scared okay the
show to give this rate shower rating
would be pg-13 get me to write because
we're not are we're not explicit no the
crazy the craziest things we talk about
is like Jacob sorry I was having sex
really Bobby right so for
thirteen-year-old yeah is this rated
pg-13 or a rated R it's rated R what's
it okay thank you it's medical I think
medical doesn't have a rating I don't
know okay whatever back to Khloe
Kardashian back to Khloe Kardashian she
allowed Tristan in the room it's unclear
whether or not she's gonna take him back
I just feel like for World Order she
can't take him back right I feel like
that I'll be like rides in the street I
just love when like celebrities and my
needs have clean power ful women like
get cheated on and they do the right
thing do you know what I mean
I just really even for like Beyonce's
brand if she had left jay-z like
empowering yeah but she didn't silly but
also like I've never cheated on I think
so like Who am I to say like then she'd
I mean I would just be like I don't care
I love you so much just like please take
me back
yeah if you want to everybody gives me
like Britney and Jack sides because she
always said if you ever cheat on me I'm
out and and he did and like she just had
to look at it differently
yeah now it's like if you ever do it
again she's out but I don't know I just
feel like to each their own and like I
would I could see her taking him back
but I think yeah but like I'm so brave
you know over here right in my happy
marriage right you know right you just
never know until it happens to you but
hopefully it never does do you migraines
like ever
I know literally like it's coming right
here you want to know something
interesting so Weatherly have never worn
a headband since middle oh yeah but I'm
here to tell you that they still of
course they were when yesterday
afternoon I was wearing it for less than
an hour and I had to take it off because
you're a masochist you know the way that
you feel wearing a headband is how you
feel when you're hungover like yeah it's
just your brain robbing like yeah I
don't know why I do it to myself
probably because I need to apologize to
the masses because for the past two days
oh my gosh so dramatic
that's terrible hair days no you didn't
see it and like because when you want to
replay it can probably don't look at me
which is oh don't [ __ ] look at me
yesterday I had crazy bumps in the back
of my bun every time I turn to look at
you was like and then the day before I
had a strand like alfalfa the whole
episode I didn't noticed either I
thought you looked wonderful thank you
but I'm like just oh I'm honestly over
Chloe interest Tristen it's nothing I've
been like thinking or speaking about for
like the past week and I'm over it
I know I just I'm a little grateful
though I just want to say thank you to
them because they really made this first
week of the breath like very juicy
yeah everyone's you know coming here to
see what we have to say totally and as
much as like all we have to say is that
we really care you call it the breath oh
my god we have to like take a shot every
time you go oh that's a good idea yeah I
won't do it now because there's a fly in
major there is I didn't want to scare
you oh well it's really a fly it's
really a fly and it's just so it's so
certain it's full fly form I'm sorry I
hope he lived a nice life I don't think
he did it looks like a baby stop okay
whatever / - Chloe interesting honestly
I don't care I'm alright um but yes you
mean the first week of the toast very
intrigued a minute so thank you very
much
this next story can be same to the next
Tori please okay and are you
dare I say China Khloe interest in no
but I'm definitely like getting there
yeah this story makes me really sad and
but it's a vessel through which we can
talk about last night's episode of
Jersey Shore okay
Jersey Shore my family vacations Jenni
JWoww Farley reveals she suffered a
miscarriage before the Italy season okay
so apparently before they started
filming in Italy which the season that
was in Florence she suffered a
miscarriage she said in tonight's
episode of Jersey Shore a family
vacation oh I missed that part be tuned
in late I watch it so basically like
she's sick kind of taking a back seat
she's like not really party and she's
hanging out with Mike a lot and they
both like weird like kind of sober they
woke up early and they're like having
this conversation he's just talking
about how he was in such a dark place
dangerous he's sure and like how when he
threw his head and tore in the cement
wall and Italy like you he wanted you
like he wanted to hurt himself he
thought it was like sheet rock and you
thought he would go through it I'm Jenni
was like no I totally get that like I
was really [ __ ] up in Italy like I was
on so many pills because like right
before Italy my grandma died and then
like literally a week later me and Roger
had a miscarriage and like I was so
devastated and it was really sad I like
hate when people talk about their
mascara does it makes me so sad
no it was important I tuned in at like 8
o said and I was wondering I'm like is
this breaking news or do people know
this already
no it was really sad and like I really
like Jenni like I think she's so mature
I love her and like okay this season of
Jersey Shore family vacation oh and I
meant to say that up until I watched a
first episode I thought Jersey Shore
family make vacation meant they were
bringing their families when they were
like we're doing Jersey Shore family
vacation with their family no but like I
saw they meant that the kids were coming
in like so it was gonna be like kids I'm
glad it's not I'm so glad it's not and I
don't think Johnny would agree to it he
obviously hates the show yeah but I
think they all agreed to it because it's
clear that there's like this element of
they're making money from the show and
that's why they're saying like Snooki
does not want to be there no one wants
to be known oh they're doing it because
a they really are very close to being
relevant and this will give them I think
another five to ten years of like
relevancy yeah yeah I know there's
another year no I disagree I've been on
the air in five years I know but five
years ago it still didn't give them five
to ten like but I did if they weren't
real celebrities now they're like
they're they're like d-list I think for
like five years I mean they'll be I
think
idealist yeah I mean then we're talking
about how like Pauly D like he's made
this whole career off of like this
reality show from so long ago like him
doing this and like just getting more
Instagram followers and like more
notoriety like this will give his DJ
career like an extension oh I completely
agree and also I'm sure they're getting
paid a lot to be there which is why I
think they're so upset with Sammi
because it's like she's taking away by
not being there it's not the same show
and she's singing away from like what it
could be and how much like I feel like
they're all in this together
but let's recap the episode because they
made me really mad it made me really mad
I told you there is this overarching
theme of depression and like no it has
been entity it's not that I think that
some of the cast members like are taking
their fame like to their heads and I've
heard things about some of the cast
members and it's starting to come out in
them do you know what I mean that you
could tell me the diva I mean we know
hear talking
ya know but like I'm in this weird place
yeah let me tell you I'm in this weird
place where I'm catching up so I'm on
season 4 watching Florence and when I
was watching the show Snooki was easily
my favorite character like I really
related she's so funny she was a show
that made the show when she got arrested
and that's what made them all so close
yeah all like had her back before that
they thought she was so weird
no no she totally and she was definitely
like the star of the show she was
probably getting paid the most back then
like she was the biggest star and I
think that that's definitely gone to her
head a little bit like you can get that
vibe and I think she thinks she's above
this and I think Jionni [ __ ] hates
everyone and hates the franchise and
like didn't want her to go but like who
is he like he doesn't really not have to
work because of all the money she made
like please and I thought she was being
really mean to Jenni and like really not
nice and like jenny was right jenny was
literally just trying to mediate she's
like stop talking about it you're
ruining my marriage what does that mean
how many times do you say you're ruining
my marriage right and you keep saying
that that's ruining your marriage right
but here's that that makes it seem like
you're ruining your marriage is ruin of
all right however like at the prom I
completely understood what how she was
feeling and why she didn't want to be
near Vinnie like so not only have they
hooked up she cheated yeah with Vinnie
and like Jionni seems from what we've
like seen about him and he might be like
a little control yeah so I understand
why he wouldn't want her near bit no
same but like but he's making it so
weird like she doesn't want to talk
about it but yet every
time she's sitting next to him she's
like move me away that's marks
conversation right so why don't you just
be like listen like there's obviously
some awkwardness here like an be better
if we're not super close but a part of
ever but then Vinny's [ __ ] up because
then Vinnie liked to get a rise out of
purse like grinding on her like that's
that that's appropriate ID no matter
which cast member it is because like she
is a married woman I agree
but there is their heart of me and
they're both right there's a part of me
that like really truly ships vidiians
dokey there's a part of me that wishes
they would all break up with their
significant others and go back to yeah
things were neat you but like that's
unrealistic how you know what's weird
it's like in the house Vinny's like kind
of like the kid brother it's like he's
scrawny everything he's not like super
Guido like the rest of them and like he
doesn't really get a lot of respect and
like he does things in the house that
you can feel the cast member the cast
mates like making fun of him for but
like in public like everyone's obsessed
with him yeah he's like the most did you
see that um I like hate BuzzFeed so I
hate to give him any press but there's
someone wrote an article like 50 times
we were horny for Vinny Guadagnino
spotty and his mind so then I put a hot
picture of him in there like one of his
tweets about like The Bachelor it was
really good yeah I feel like it's so
it's it's strange how he's treating the
house versus how like he's the most like
palatable I totally agree the public um
I also like I just I can't [ __ ] stand
Ronnie he wasn't even really in this
episode first of all they have got to
stop with the Doody jokes like that was
funny ten years ago it's not funny
anymore
and it's actually discussing it and it's
like you guys are literally
multimillionaires like call a [ __ ]
plumber totally I thought you had to
leave a voicemail there's more than one
plumber Miami
Judy jokes are the lowest form of humor
and they were kind of funny like in 2010
when they first did it cuz it was like
really funny because they were actually
living in squalor and they were like it
maybe that's like majors and there were
young kids they were broke like now
they're rich millionaires they don't
need to be living in a house with a
toilet that doesn't work right call the
damn Hummer they were out all day the
plumber could have came like I [ __ ]
just hate Ronnie like the show's making
me so mad look the more I think about it
the more I'm watching old seasons new
seasons he hasn't changed he he's a
monster like I really can't stand him
his conversation with his yeah oh yeah
what are you doing that's okay and yes
Hollies reactions to paulie's the best
he's the best he also confuses me
because there's also now this like
weird dichotomy to use your favorite
word because he says like they were
really the most successful care he has
like the most money and there's like
this sort of deference towards him
because of that but there never was
before like he was always just like I'm
the jokester prankster like but one took
him seriously
what does deference mean like respect
yeah so but yes I don't know if that has
to do with the money though because he
was always he was always the jokester he
never got involved in drama he managed
to be like everyone's friends stay
really relevant and didn't never got
into one fight ya know I just feel like
there's just something weird the whole
thing is so weird the whole show the
whole show is I'm loving it and hating
it at the same exact time I don't know
if I would like this episode was not
good did some gay ever find her range
yes Tina found it we're in the grass I'm
yeah but like I don't know I'm just like
I'm fixated on Snooki's marriage and
I've read some lines about it I'm not
gonna lie do I I don't I love them I
know and I just I just love Jenni she
came on the old show when I knew and she
was like so fancy but she yeah and like
it's did she co-host or did she guest
she gets it okay um and I just had such
a good time with her and I've always
like loved her from the show because she
is like so responsible so smart yeah oh
he's like pigs like they're a tag team
and yes like Snooki is the star but like
without Jenni like it wouldn't have been
the same go hand in hand and so for to
see somebody disrespecting her was not
no like so rude
shut up Jenni you've never been called
an idiot before like I really was really
pissing me off yeah but then it's also
like they're also drunk and yes it's
like soon he was like if I take one more
sip I'm gonna back out it's like I feel
like this was the plan for the show like
this was the strategy board like get the
cast back together black out hope for
the best
yeah totally fingers crossed something
funny happens when they're I don't think
that they like black out on the Reg and
they don't there's no like it's weird
it's just yeah I'm curious just if
Snooki's gonna wake up and say sorry or
wake up in like I hate when people that
do things when they're drunk and then
like stand by them when they're sober
just I can make you for wrong it's not a
big deal no and then you can blame it on
being drunk and it's wonderful and let's
move on you know and like it's relate
about like oh I've been there yeah and I
one thing that they do on Jersey Shore
that I find to be very relatable is like
they all get really drunk but then they
also show how like alcohol not to be
like sound like a counselor or something
but like how alcohol is a depressant
yeah and the next day they're all happy
they have like I
and they feel weird and like and I feel
like there was especially during the old
show like Vinny had to go home because
he had anxiety yeah and I think a lot of
that stems from alcohol so I like how
they show yeah alcohol is really fun but
it really is a depressant and like it
can really affect your mood and you're
just I don't know I know that that
alcohol is a depressant but I've never
experienced that of you yes oh my god
you know in my life recently like now
every time I drink I don't drink a lot
anymore no it's so annoying in the past
like six months I think the last time
well now it's like when we have
something I'll go hard for like Ben's
birthday oh yeah you know he went out
with my human hard and went home early
yeah because I get two day hangovers now
and I mean the toast was premiering and
it was just like this is not the time to
have a hangover and when I'm with my
friends a few weeks ago we turned it up
but now my hangovers are just so bad so
I my drinking has just become very
measured but that's just a symptom of
getting older that's like I I lived in
my heyday and I and now I went to
college you know now I just like have a
glass of wine or two and that's my night
and you know it's really nice I don't
like wine it gives me a headache and
like I feel like everyone around me it's
like growing up like I went to dinner
with all my friends let's say and they
split a bottle of 71 bug-like
I had two margaritas like I'm just up
there yet yeah then maybe it's cuz I
feel like that because I got married so
young like I want to retain my youth
also you didn't start drinking and I
remember this one night and you were
like oh my god alcohol like you were
Brielle no I know and I when I said I
liked it I drink in high school and like
I thought I was drinking do you know
anything of course and like then I
realize like the entire time I was in
high school like I never once got drunk
yeah I mean II like actually got drunk
and it was like I was hungover you know
yeah yeah and then I was like starting
to feel tingly but like I don't know I
just I'm not even close to being done
drinking yet do you know what I mean and
I feel like all my friends are kind of
like phasing out of it like oriental
stop by my own and like and I'm just so
not there and maybe it's cause like I
want to retain my you know Tinsley more
number party girls socially like
pathetic or also because like I feel
like I have to keep up with everyone cuz
like everyone thinks I'm like old and
married but I'm not no it'll it'll
happen to you don't choose when it
happens to you like I started getting
such bad hangover said every time I had
that and I was like I'm never drinking
and obviously that only works for so
long but this has been going on for like
a year not to an hour I'm at the point
where it's like even now I'm not
hungover and I can't even handle this
side of a hangover how oh and I also got
pretty trashed at the Super Bowl
but also Jenner not in Gossard I've just
discovered Pedialyte which is really
really really helped me but no in
college I'd be like have a crazy night
out I'd wake up for my 8:30 like ooh I
have a headache and like my neck I'm
fine I know totally now it's like if I
wake up hungover I'm hungover until I go
to sleep that night except on Sunday I
woke up hungover and I was like oh my
god like I can't deal with this the
toast is tomorrow but by the grace of
God the hangover stopped at like 2
o'clock yeah and that was just like
heaven turns into like a headache
yeah and like it's just very like
centralized and yeah one spot spot okay
well that was our recap of the Jersey
Shore and the dangers of alcohol yeah um
also we won't speak about this now but I
just want to talk about southern charm
in a little bit because justice for
Naomi JD is a fraudulent Pig so that
there in a second but this third story I
knew this somehow I owe someone with
inside scoop told me Amy Schumer parts
way I told you who and who told you
didn't tell you you did tell I was with
you no you weren't okay Amy Schumer
parts ways with manager who used to date
her husband okay this is why the story
is so crazy and not a lot of people know
this because Amy Schumer like randomly
got married to a guy she was saving for
two weeks and everyone was like so
surprised by it it was so crazy and it
was so crazy but what was even crazier
about it that wasn't really in the press
was that this guy was the longtime
boyfriend of her publicist carried
Bialik right yeah and like Amy used to
joke all the time about her she like was
in love with carries boyfriend and she
loved the boyfriend love the boyfriend
the boyfriend and then literally two
seconds later she's married to the
boyfriend so her publicist Carrie Bialik
was not at the wedding but she was still
technically her publicist up until now
it's the weirdest story ever that is
really weird and now I'm feeling I him
remembering how you know it wasn't there
but you did such a good job of
recruiting don't like you were like I
was there it's so weird and this woman
carry me like I used to follow her on
Instagram because she's like the best
publicist in the world and she only
takes on like like three clients like
Stephen Colbert and Amy Schumer are just
our clients and I just like wanted to
see her life and I just think this whole
situation is so bizarre so bizarre
however I just want to use this as an
opportunity to talk about how excited I
am for I feel pretty me too
looks like the greatest movie up the
greatest movie since a train wreck yeah
I saw a lot of backlash for it though
why because of like because basically
like I think the movie has such a good
message
yeah if you're as confident as you feel
no matter how you look right and then a
lot of the backlash was saying that like
Amy Schumer as like a thin white woman
can't even complain about thinking she's
not pretty but you how are you to say I
totally but that someone's like should
feel pretty just cuz what you think they
look like yeah no I love her meet you I
mean she's clearly not like like a
double zero model right no no and that's
what's wrong that's what she feels like
I can't deny bottling is just like an
option for me I think so but it's not
every it looks sponsored by SoulCycle
all the commercials have that that scene
with the girl wearing the t-shirt - I
just thought it was like they could have
done it a regular like cycling place
that's so interesting
it must be sponsored I hope it is also
so cycle is um those great sponsorships
but one that's really disappointing me
is I just went to like on Monday this
you're gonna like make fun of me but
they always have SmartWater like forever
in here and they gave me a bottle of
Fiji which is disgusting no it's
disgusting and also SmartWater has a
sport cap so you can really just grab it
while you're on them like this one had a
short happen but this square bottle is
not conducive for like also aren't the
the bottle holders in the round round to
defend feet she's nasty
yeah and it's you're a little snot no
it's literally taste I'd rather drink
tap water for sure and I'm for $0 it's
so thick it's so thick it's it's worse
than like dasami
okay so everything you know you read
some of them be on and tell me the story
didn't need me after bottled water hmm
page six is exclusively learned that
Schumer has parted ways with her
longtime PR at manager in the midst of a
massive movie promo for I feel pretty oh
that's where that she did fire her
publicists like in the midst of a
massive movie promo and their
relationships with the same man are
partly to blame it's so weird our
publicist and manager Carrie violet who
helped turn Schumer into one of the
biggest comedy stars on the planet dated
Schumer's brand new husband Chris Fisher
way back in 2007 while sources close to
Schumer in Bialik say that it was quote
just time for them to go their separate
ways
we're told that after Schumer and Fisher
tied the knot in February Schumer and
Beyond likes relationship fell apart no
[ __ ]
during their time as rep and client
Schumer had made a string of hit movies
and famously landed a hugely lucrative
netflix deal what is it that a good
Netflix special eye
is that hugely everyone has one I can
use Amy Schumer on my Netflix like a TV
show form I need to watch I show the
last og with Tiffany Haddish and Tracy
Morgan I'm so glad Tracy Morgan is back
on television he's so Evan I just bought
her book the last pack unicorn and I'm
so good I didn't mean I'm gonna save it
for Jack Evans books in ten seconds yeah
I bought our keychains but but I'm
waiting cuz we're going on a trip in two
weeks and like I want to enjoy it like
not on an airplane like on the beach I
read it on my flight to Dallas and I
finished it an hour before we land look
why is that enjoyable it's just I guess
it's a page-turner and also there was no
actually I did have my iPad I don't know
I just I want to get to the bottom of
the story and also we it's a lot of
backstory her book and I wanted to get
to Beverly Hills so there that's
probably why okay what else is done um
and you know what since I read so
quickly and like I should probably read
books with like substance yeah like I
don't know Anna Karenina is that story
what's the Tolstoy book that one are you
sure I believe so okay also maybe like a
lot of war oh my or maybe like a little
Homer oh yes and those other one lyses
know the ill assist ulysses no thank you
right there lyses Ulysses Grant I don't
know I just I can't believe we've never
spoken about this Amy Schumer thing
because I found out this information and
I was like why do people like why is
this not in the press like that she
literally is something that the press
could put together you know and she's
very public with her publicist like her
publicist is like ten thousand Instagram
followers she's not like private so I
don't know what I found this out I was
shook to the [ __ ] core
Duren said Carrie's kind of a genius she
got Amy Vogue she got her GQ so many big
things amy was on the cover of Vogue I
don't think the cover oh so maybe not so
many big things yes to make matters
worse Bialik brought the whole situation
on herself
we're told that Fisher's younger sister
Molly ass Bialik for help finding work
and V Alec introduced her to Schumer who
hired her as her assistant
Molly then introduced Schumer to Chris
and they got married just a few months
later whoo we're told that while a
number of Schumer's exes were at the
malibu nuptials the couple didn't invite
Bialik in spite of her long with Schumer
amid the drama Schumer's unfollowed
Bialik on instagram : bye
her to her wedding yeah that's how I
knew something was up
the Alec told paid chicks people are
always trying to make a story more
interesting than reality this sounds
pretty interesting to us reality seems
awesome right now our business
relationship ended for many reasons but
has no connection to someone I briefly
dated over a decade ago years before I
even met Amy I couldn't be happier for
her personally and professionally and
through our working relationship and
though our working relationship ended we
remained good friends shook I'd love a
story like this yeah I'm happy Schumer I
hope this is like a long lasting thing
even though just like Emily bond and
Michael Buble I will always ship her and
the furniture designer I thought like he
was so good for her no he was good for
that you know but I feel like she is too
powerful of a woman to like date a
powerful man you know I mean he wasn't
powerful but like I don't know he had me
like alien vibes that's perfect
what does this guy do Fischer he's a
chef a celebrity respect he's a
celebrity chef perfect
no but it's celebrity I love everything
about Amy Schumer but I'm gonna say one
thing I did not like her wedding dress
like at all I didn't even look at it
it was like it was just not a good
choice it's fast anyone I go up and down
with Amy Schumer I used to be like so so
so yeah you went to her I've seen her
stand-up yeah um I used to watch inside
Amy Schumer clips like oh by the way
that's why you remember you couldn't
feel about her that was a Netflix
special oh yeah I just I found out now
you can't tell my comedy shows most of
them because like that people put it
online and then the jokes aren't like
you can't yeah when you hear the jokes a
second time it makes no sense at my
comedy show people weren't allowed to be
aware left why was that because I think
somebody said I didn't make it up I
think it's a big comedy venue think I'll
talk to some of my comic friends and get
back to I remember
sorry automatic number one we went to
removing to a comedy show and with Chris
- Stephanie from girl code and I had
watched all their comedy online before I
like to get about it and then I went to
the show and was all the same it was so
disappointing yeah like that's the best
joke Carly Aquilino made it
she's like my boyfriend one time call me
a huge [ __ ] and like I didn't know the
dropping you knew it and she goes you
did not just call me huge and like you
had laughed at it already
I think I ruined it yeah for that for
whatever anyways happy for Amy Schumer
amy was on the cover of Vogue and
Netflix paid her 15 million dollars for
a Netflix special says Candice king in
the comments on Facebook I'm gonna make
sure that's true she sounds like she
knows anyone with the last name king for
sure yeah okay next story makes me happy
Jamie Lynn Spears welcomes a baby girl
IV Joan and this time the father is not
a rapist
yeah allegedly allegedly um the actress
and singer welcome to her second child
and first with her husband Jamie Watson
daughter I've the Joan Watson on
Wednesday April 11th at 10:02 a.m. what
were you doing oh we were getting ready
for the toast I was right here imagine
we were sitting here Jamie Lynn pushing
pushing out ID Joan her rep confirms two
people exclusively I love Jamie Lynn
Spears um seems I wish good things for
her a little beautiful right you really
delivery
okay that's they released it to people
so she know you should so makeup on I
mean good totally like I want so many
pictures in my delivery but I want to
look good a popular thing now it's to
hire a photographer in the delivery room
I can't think of anything I would want
less I'm at my fattest my sweatiest am I
most uncomfortable and I want a
photographer up my vagina no I don't
need a photographer like taking pictures
of the birth but like maybe two hours
later I could get like a little spur
single touch up they a little powder yes
let's stitch up that machine and then we
can do a reenactment we've been talking
a lot about vaginas today what was the
first thing that I came of Chloe oh yeah
so two big two births do you think IV
and Tristan Thompson and Chloe's
daughter will ever hang out no no but
you know what like they're being crazy
or things that have happened in this
world
yeah so Never Say Never Nev like in the
wake of Marco becoming a princess Jackie
in the words of Justin Bieber Never Say
Never
I will fight you forever oh yeah I don't
know the words
this isn't your song no not at all okay
speaking of your song Oh mr. magazine
rate I'm obsessed with Mason Ramsey they
call him the yodeling Walmart kid but I
know him as missing Ramsey they call him
the Walmart yodeling kid
I call him baby whose child is a hundred
percent in for Coachella you guys this
story is insane I'm reading every word
the kid who went viral for yodeling at a
Walmart he's about to take his act to
the desert and if the stars align he'll
be performing at Coachella with post
Malone TMZ has learned sources close to
11 year-old Mason Ramsey what sources do
he hat does he have other than his grams
from Golconda Illinois tell us he's set
to share the stage with some of music's
hottest acts starting at 2:45 p.m.
Friday with we thin and up-and-coming
deejay funny story hwisun actually
tweeted about Mason after he went viral
he said stop saying I look like the
Walmart Yoda Lincoln haha we're told
several other artists have reached out
including post E is that when people
call no okay
wanting to feature Mason's yodeling
magic during their Coachella set but
thanks to Ellen DeGeneres
he's already booked at the Grand Ole
Opry for Saturday which is when the
rapper scheduled our sources say his
team is still trying to make it happen
with post Malone though it will just
have to wait until weekend two of the
festival okay this is the thing like
only weekend one matters like this is me
right now not a Coachella living my best
life in a cool temperature droom with
not the most awful people surrounding me
like I'm so grateful humbled and honored
to not be at Coachella this year but
this is making me like a little foam oh
right the best part about this story is
that there are a couple toasters who are
on his flight right now
oh yes the deadzone are mourning
toasters Facebook group which is serving
a premium content at all times one girl
is on a flight I think it's to the
desert right but yeah it just seems to
me at the Opry tomorrow yeah but like
that's when your Mason Ramsay like yeah
the world is your oyster
I'm sure fine private I'm sure Ellen's
gonna send a plane for him it's so crazy
that up until last week Ian never been
on a plane before and now he's
definitely been on like a dozen planes
and I'm sure he's gonna be fine private
and he is more miles than like the
points guy he is more miles and miles
davis he has more miles in miles teller
healer miles and me oh I love him so
much but like I still gave a little bit
of a pain when I speaking of miles
teller him and his fiancee are I'm like
an engagement moon Kelly Kelly
in Bora Bora which is like goals because
like that's where I want to go and
that's where cam dropped her diamond
earrings yeah
and I just wanna say they're serving a
premium content and like we were talking
about this before like she's taking sexy
bikini pics like you
miles taking the pictures yeah he is
more like a waiter
I feel like miles has like an artistic
side to know or he is like a like a you
know secret love for photography no I
feel like he definitely has a creative
eye you know I would like to place like
badly lit photos no I feel it's also
Bora Bora there's like no bad lighting
that's true but sometimes like the sun's
behind you yeah I don't know I'm just
I'm really that's one place I do want to
go like where the huts are on yeah water
look I wonder if it's as great as it
looks it definitely is better than it
looks dude yeah how long is the fight so
long like like 20 hours like I'm in bed
montoya for our honeymoon and my friend
Margo fish just got married also wanted
to go there and like she actually
planned out I spent dinner she's going
in July and it's 20 hours when are you
going on your honey I don't know where
are you going I don't know I don't know
I'm just like I want to go on like
should have just done it like right a
because now I'm never gonna do it yeah
and then New York just gonna be talking
about it forever like we still have to
go on our honeymoon you're gonna be like
no it's like we're not even gonna be
like happy to be with each other because
we're like over each other over
definitely I was actually that's okay
now that's a learning lesson for me but
like I was juggling goddamn busy I don't
know how anyone could plan a wedding and
a honeymoon yeah no I would plan a
honeymoon for like a month after because
I definitely want to still ride the high
like people who leave from their wedding
to their honeymoon it's like don't you
want to like get all your texts and like
just see what gifts you got you're being
distracted no people are saying we're
wrong about 20 hours oh wait they just
arrested a new suspect in Kim K's
robbery breaking news that's what
someone said to be a People magazine
another one tonight someone's getting
the link I think at a news notification
so it's not real yet and also I'm Margot
Lewin who's a friend of ours is watching
and she said honestly bar bars and all
it's cracked up to be it's so humid or
not let's ask Kelly yeah Kelly will you
let us know thank you wow I can't
believe they arrested someone else but
like a little late French government
it's been like a year over a year
yeah okay that happened and I can't
believe that interview she have an
island like it was so epic she's like
and I kind of understand her just like I
just feel like this was meant to happen
to me cuz if it hadn't happened like she
was just going going going on going like
I don't know it could have been someone
she said something so with like a
profound she's like I'm just so glad my
kids get to grow up with like this me as
a mom and not like the old me that is
really profound
I love her me too and I love me some
Ramsey and I still got a pit every time
I see a video of him just be like people
are like laughing I've got him and I
just feel like the like suckers at
Coachella like do not deserve him no no
I totally agree like if you go to
Coachella sorry you're a terrible person
and you don't deserve to see Mason
Ramsay Mason Ramsay seriously should be
head lighting stagecoach that's a real
good idea oh my goodness golden voice is
the company that produces you're welcome
yeah singing with Kacey Musgraves cuz
she yodels - yes I bet they all yodel
Mary Morstan I can't do you know what I
mean
yeah except if you want to get technical
technically he's not yodeling in Walmart
he's just singing a country song but
that has yodels in it
no yes checking you when he goes like
this oh I do was it yeah that's yodel
that that uptick I don't know yo -
yodeling is just this song I'd only yeah
yeah yeah yeah the LeAnn Rimes hug I
wanna be a cowboy sweetheart I want to
learn to rope and ride I wanna tan
during the ride in the desert how waves
in the Great Divide I wanna hear the
cowboy sing has the Sun sets in the west
I wanna be a cowboy sweet that's alive I
love the best - you're late yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're late I just can't
believe yes yes to love that song and
it's by LeAnn Rimes and she's so Brandi
Glanville's goddamn my friend that's
crazy I just love how the world works
and like she wasn't like the Taylor
Swift of her time remember that's long
back and we like can't fight the naughty
in the dark and then eventually deformed
on X Factor and like was drunk and I
couldn't open her eyes it knows the
world is amazing it is as if like Taylor
Swift grew up to steal a Real Housewives
husband yet before they're even a real
house yeah to steal like a ugly Betty's
uncle that's who he was on Ugly Betty he
played her sister's boyfriend oh my god
you're right
yeah who got shot you're totally right
Taylor so I started stealing and messing
him I just I will never be over how the
world works because it works amazing
leann rimes it's like such a yodeling
song and like I think that we're doing
it like you're layin oh yeah I want me
sin Ramsey to do a cover of that I'm
sure he does I'm sheriff equation
through his g-tube no let's put a
request in I'll send him an email
yes okay oh this that was actually our
five stories I just have a couple other
tabs on the story Jerry Springer's
former producer Jill Blackstone was
arrested for the murder of her sister
the story was actually so crazy and when
I was reading it they're gonna be on
Khloe Kardashian's show that we're gonna
decide and I was also thinking the bike
away that she did it she was definitely
inspired by what she saw I'm Jerry
Springer for sure I mean you don't you
can't be in that kind of environment
every day and not want to kill your own
sister I went to one screening of one
episode and I came back and all hell
broke loose and then the next story was
which was almost gonna be the Fast Five
but it didn't make the cut what we're
talking about is the cast of Dancing
with the Stars completely uninteresting
the fact that Tonya Harding is on it and
it's just like once again where's the
justice for a Nancy Kerrigan because I
don't see it
and also Adam rip on oh yeah it's a very
olympic-themed I've heard oh yeah oh
wait no there's Adam rip on figure
skater there's Chris Mads dur who's a
loser
there is Jenny thinge Daigle who's in an
Olympic softball player and there Ryan
gusu who's a figure skater who landed a
triple axel the girl the trimmer I yeah
and Tonya Harding who's a former Olympic
figure skater okay also I want to talk
to you because I watched I Tanya I don't
think I ever talked to you about how it
made me feel how did it make you feel um
here's the thing like it was definitely
a rewriting of history of course but it
was a good movie no not even that like I
understand why they felt like they
needed to tell this story oh my god are
you kidding me like I don't know what
why I just I can't say the words but if
I could I would be saying
justice for Tommy Harding what like I
don't know it just she she just couldn't
had to break really cuz it seems like
she caught the break of all breaks by
being an Olympic flame what do you mean
she couldn't got to break she got the
break of a lifetime to be in the
Olympics she went about some [ __ ]
trash town she nobody makes it out of
that town
look at her him up with the birds are
you initially just surrounded herself by
like terrible terrible people so she
made bad decisions had poor judgment got
a break refused to use it ruined her
life and you want justice for her I
don't want because I want justice for
the girl whose dream it was to go to the
Olympics and you win it and we got her
knees bashed it and she went and got her
knees bashed in when she went so your
now does auntie Nancy carry I'm not
auntie hair but when Tonya Harding or
Margot Robbie said like when she won she
wasn't even smiling I thought oh my god
it's just like you're kidding me no
here's thing I'm always gonna be team
auntie no one part of the movie that was
absolutely hysterical I was like she was
getting beat by her husband all the time
and she's like a Nancy Kerrigan gets
beat once and the whole world can know
and like she obviously grew up it like
in an abusive house yeah but Allison
Janney totally deserved Oscar right yes
I just like it made me I never felt in
ounce of sorry for her whatsoever cuz
I'd also didn't know the whole story
like we grew up in like the post
banality watching when it was just
decided that MIT we were all team Nancy
and as we were right I would love to see
I Nancy I would love to but like I time
you just made me feel like a man who
would play Nancy like honestly Leighton
Meester honestly they should have
Margaret Nancy - totally that would be
so that would be so epic but like just
it's like Nancy Kerrigan is like an
Olympian she's just so pure and like the
best thing that ever happens to her like
she gets sitting out with the Patriots
cheerleaders like no but this is like 20
years later or like 15 years later I'm
just I think back in the day like she
was on like all she did the whole like
rain Sergei yeah I don't know I'm just
I'm really upset like that your
introduction no I just I didn't think
for one second I thought I would be able
to enjoy the movie and separate the
truth from the new narrative and I
really just cut it and I was surprised
by that cuz usually like I'm like
that's me yeah let's before we wrap up
for the week let's talk about southern
charm yes because I don't watch but I
was keeping up with a lot of the drama
on Twitter and it seems like this is
just an outsider's perspective like
Elizabeth is like totally an abusive
relationship because she's acting like a
prisoner exactly
southern charm is one of the greatest
shows it's one of the greatest shows on
Bravo and I feel like it's underrated
but you say it does really really well
yes the most popular show I just feel
like no one watches it because you don't
want it Real Housewives of Atlanta
southern charm and Ben approvals are
like the top three shows well I'm really
happy because I love southern charm this
is the season of the women like I've
said finally a little bit of Justices
cap for Catherine is being served
because like the men on this show are
out of control
JD I don't know what his last name is
like you think it's like Gentry is a con
it's his lessons D J D comma J yeah he's
a con artist he is vile his businesses
are a fraud and you know what I used to
think Zak oh we said Zak watches he's
like JD gives me the willies
I mean I used to think like wow what a
great guy like he uses the family man he
uses a show to further his bourbon well
it seemed like the Bourbon was
everywhere but note was just like the
places they were going where he would
like bring it bro
Mobe it's like and they all doing Ghent
you like what does it even taste like
it's definitely just like from the river
it's totally [ __ ] okay anyways I'm so
here for his takedown the way that Naomi
came for him was epic it was everything
and he just like he's so manipulative to
the point where I feel like he I just I
can't I think Elizabeth his his wife now
taking steps back on Twitter she's like
egad that naomi is like exploiting my
private life and saying untrue lies like
he's maybe better things to do like
being a French businesswoman like yes
rather than take down a relationship
that no me has better things to do
she's watching the toast she's a
hardcore toaster yes she has episodes of
the toast of me watching like she
doesn't need to be saving your ass
that's like not so we see next week that
Elizabeth comes to Patricia's party with
JD I'm like her and Naomi have a fight
and it's like oh my god that would piss
me off so much if I were Naomi and now I
guess it's it's permanent because
elizabeth is defending JD on Twitter but
like just Google JD like all of his
business are fraudulent every year they
have that Caroline
party we're like they're swinging and
dancing and it was always at his
establishment which has closed but it's
like I'm the show you would think like
oh yeah this thing for the places jump
in harvey levin wheelin dealin billion
dealin fraudulent business transactions
yeah and it's just also fake which is so
crazy because the way that he put on
this front is like you would have never
known that he was like Bernie Madoff
England right down birdie Bernie Madoff
good birdie I didn't know you did well I
did him you know what's so great is that
we have this whole thing filmed and we
could see what you said but I don't
either of us would watch it no no I'm
going on up to this and then I had one
more thing to say
Katherine justice for Katherine she's
being like so mature so elegant this
season and a really bothered me when
Thomas was saying to ask you that he
felt like Katherine ever loved him like
all Katherine didn't like him too much
that she couldn't like stop loving him
and get work on herself that was really
[ __ ] pissed me off I'm sorry that I
don't watch a show cuz like I really I
think you should start from season one I
was just like I'm so not Justin like a
really light chef yeah and I really like
Naomi I'm like that's literally it and
Cameron thank Cameron yeah yeah okay
it's like I watch enough like reality
shows with white people do you know any
mean yeah no it's definitely very white
it's the whitest show yeah well it's
work something that's working everyone
loves it okay
is that it do we have anything else we
are wrapping up our first we up the toe
how would you rap give me three words
okay whirlwind of course Christy yes
what see Jess can I get like a three
word three bird no three word third word
okay work in progress
double you look a little wet WI T
totally I think today is our best show
yet if you look at the stream our
blighting is fantastic I'm like well
like I said we said on the first day the
only place to go from here is up like
every day the lighting has gotten better
we've gotten better fern placement has
gotten better we have these beautiful
flowers from Mikie Russo that our have
our logo and like they really just added
just a pop of color
no we're so like green no I know where
it's like we're so ecological I'm so
glad all these plants are faker at us I
would be so sneezy because it's allergy
season y'all so a week in I want to say
big thanks to all the toasters we've had
record high numbers this week we were
just adding up our numbers and like
we're really proud of ourselves it
just been great I think like during the
break I think we were just like unsure
like what we would do and if people
would watch and like now that we're back
and like we're in control and it's like
we're female to own business our
business is generating no revenue but
like we're so we're female owned
business
yeah like small business owners yes
female entrepreneurs you know like they
have small business in America that's
about us now like yeah today it's like a
national holiday oh man I can't wait to
celebrate
I know so a cheer a toast to the toes to
the toes one week in thank you to the
toasters for the major support make sure
you're following our Instagram the
morning toast Facebook YouTube Twitter
and actually on Twitter only bad things
happen on Twitter I don't want to be in
a ringer there this champagne smells
make sure your palms host and then also
make sure you're following Jackie O
problems scrub with ninjago club with on
job boy with ended up do with no job we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time you can listen to us in the
podcast app if you want to leave the
five star review if you don't if you
want to leave anything less than that
you can just scram and we will see you
guys before start reviewing everything I
love this show
like there's no negative I can
understand leaving a one-star a
three-star or five-star I don't see the
need for a to air for i yeah the show's
mediocre three if this show sucks a
while and if it's fantastic a five but
it's like even when I have a bad at
Weber driver I always give a 5 because
it's like giving a four it might as well
give a what you tried know if you've
been before you might as well give the
one it's not a five like I put on
bronzer today like I deserve a five star
also like maybe would be fun if we got
to number one in the podcast that yeah
but I thought you wanted to be only
number two it could be fun I don't know
so make sure you patch up on all that
we've never been number one all the
episodes are on Facebook they're in
YouTube and they're on the podcast app
if you're a commuter we're back on
Monday everyone have an amazing we can
stay safe and make sure to drink lots of
Pedialyte thank you for being toasty bye